i just can't even imagine the scene of
her taking the leash leeches off of your
um
because that really is you're right it's
really my butt
that's channing tatum keeping it real
about filming a nude scene with sandra
bullock 11 seconds i can feel them
suckers
in their new movie the lost city
sandra's character helps channing with a
sucky situation but he told ellen
degeneres in real life sandy is
sensational she's like everything you
want her to be like every like i think
we all have our you know our assumptions
on how people are before you meet them
and you're kind of afraid to meet them
because you're just like i don't want
them not to be what i hope them right to
be and she just is every bit yeah as
lovely as you want her to be yeah she's
and funny and down for anything for
anything but i just can't even imagine
the scene of her taking the leash
leeches off of your
um
because that really is your ass really
my butt sandra book right looking uh huh
right down the barrel right uh if you
will like it's uh right yep
i can feel them suckers
and get this channing ends up saving
sandra's behind in the film too there's
a scene where you're pushing her up a
mountain
with your head
and
she's thankfully very
very life and very agile so she was
helping me but yes i basically have to
help her up this mountain so i i jam my
my head as far as it'll go up her rumpus
and uh
get her on up the mountain
get her get it done
et spoke with sandra earlier this month
she shared how she explained all that
nudity stuff to her 10 year old daughter
lila i discussed everything i said
there's going to be there's there's some
blood it's okay and there's some having
discussions with the penis and i said i
didn't see it and lila was just she
she's convinced i did but i said i
didn't i saw nothing and at the movies
premiere the oscar winner revealed she
first met channing through her daughter
under less than desirable circumstances
we met in the principal's office at
preschool
i'm not kidding
our daughters uh are both very
strong-headed young girls
and they had it out for each other
and jan and jenna and i would get calls
we were praying it was the other
person's kid we're like please let it
have been everly please
and so we learned how to navigate their
um dislike for each other during the
freezing and then they're falling in
love and and
you know like when you've been parents
in trouble in the principal's office it
sort of bonds you
and turns out we'll be seeing a lot more
of chaney's backside thanks to magic
mike 3.
[Music]
you've been getting in shape getting
ready for magic mike three right
i'm
i'm very
i'm very sore i'm my body eggs we're in
rehearsal with allison right now as
twitch knows it's uh it's very intense
but yes we're deep in it and how how
many what are you doing to get ready for
it obviously choreography yes and and
starving yourself lots of no eating
lots more of no eating uh and then and
then on the bike a lot it takes a lot
longer to get in shape now
now the real question on fans minds will
matthew mcconaughey return as dallas the
strip club boss he played in the first
film you cannot touch
i think i see a lot of law breakers up
in this house
[Applause]
and i don't see a cop inside
the 52 year old told e.t last year he's
ready to saddle up if shannon can buy in
dallas
wherever he is i think he's probably
still in the united states he might he
might be in france somewhere doing a
show i don't know but wherever he is
he's he he's he's hustling they can pull
dallas back and it's the right kind of
story
i'd be honored to go back and get dallas
shoes and channing safe to say he's
working hard to make it happen i would
love that i didn't know if i didn't know
matthew would want to do it i mean
because he he loved what he did in the
first movie so much he kind of was just
like i don't want to touch it like he
was sort of like it was because it was i
mean he was the whole man
yeah like i i mean it and i'm not saying
anything about mine or anybody else's
performance he was the movie like he was
the special i remember i can't tell you
how many times i had to watch the movie
because of different edits that stephen
would do and i would just fast forward
it to like when he blew the fire
screen you're just like oh the movie
starts like now and it's just yeah he's
a swan song
[Music]
you